kansas city is going to be facing the
right-hander willie peralta and boy has
really been good lately 17th start this
season coming up today
in his in 13 of his 16 starts this year
he's allowed three earned runs or fewer
line left field and that's going to be
up the line and down into the corner
that's right that's his first hit of the
series and the royals will have a runner
at second base with nobody out
and nikki lopez drops one down third
base side
forcing peralta to field and he couldn't
pick it up with his bare hand and now
ben and tindy with a chance to drive in
a run
that stayed up and there's a line drive
into right field and the royals take the
lead on andrew benintendi's 24th rbi
this month the most for him in any month
of his big league career chris bubich
who is making his third start and fourth
appearance against the tigers this year
and badou chased an elevated fastball
and strikes out
on the ground left side monday cuts it
off
three up three down and at the end of
one the royals lead one nothing
[Applause]
cameron nice running catch in the corner
in right field to retire isbell to start
the second
the pitch
is sliced to the right side down into
the corner that's a base hit and chasing
it is cameron by the time he gets there
merrifield has himself a two base hit so
whit has been up twice in this game and
has two doubles
in the air to right daz cameron is there
it will work
the 1-1 is a change-up hit up the middle
nice play backhanded stop by wood
merrifield to his feet and he throws
accurately
to get erik haas at first base
good room on the ground in the hole
nice range by mondacy the throw dropped
by santana
goodrem safe and the tigers keep the
inning alive
that pops out of another glove
it's a called third strike and the
tigers strand two in the second
shallow center that's a long run
and goodrum going out from short is not
able to make the play
and that'll drop for carlos santana
putting an end to an 0 for 22. and the
royals have the bases loaded with two
down
the 1-2 popped up
haas
with room
second time the royals have left them
loaded thanks to willie perovo getting
out of the jam
[Music]
to center field again
isbell is there
and the tigers go down in order in the
bottom of the third
driven to right field cameron goes into
the corner and that's going to bounce
over the wall for a double
the royals have him at the corners now
with nobody out
and that's hit to center field
badou tries to get behind it but all of
his momentum is going backward and now
cam comes down from third on the lopez
sac fly
and the royals lead two nothing in the
fourth
fastball struck him out
and that was just right down the middle
here you go and bubbitch has four
a chopper up the middle nice play by
lopez
but paredes is aboard thanks to an
infield single and the tigers have two
men on in the first hit of the day
first and second two down royals leading
two nothing the pitch from bubic change
up grounded to the shortstop nikki lopez
he'll fire across
and that will be out number three
come on to see into foul ground three up
three down and five scoreless innings
for chris mubich
two two swung on and missed eric holland
takes care of whitmer field and down go
the royals one two three for the first
time today
a bullet out of the reach of whitmer
field
that's legit to start the sixth
now the pitch and a fastball grounded a
third monteci over to second one
mirrorfield the relay two
make it 20. five four three the double
play the pitcher's best friend two down
nobody on
candelario hits a slow roller out to
whit
and that is six scoreless innings for
chris bubich and the royals lead two
nothing to the seventh
from the stretch the two two's swinging
a miss trans fall down in ghana
[Applause]
deep third
and candelario is
in time salvi
getting up the line there and making it
close boy what kind of a message does
that say to the dugout you better
believe that and so it's up to modesty
here if the royals are going to keep
this inning going first and second two
down
mondas he pops it up
haas locates it
and he's got it
so bubitch has six scoreless innings
he is only allowed two hits
and a swing and a miss and a beautiful
changeup outside takes the bait swings
and misses making five strikeouts on the
day for chris bubich pitch from chris
bubich and a swing and a miss he strikes
him out and chris bubich
seven scoreless innings
six strikeouts
what a day for bubic who allows just two
base hits
gets caught looking
joe jimenez retires the royals one two
three
detroit's within striking distance
they'll try and do it against the kc
bullpen next
merrifield drives one to deep left field
and that ball is caught
castro crashing into the wall
robbed him of a home run
he doesn't have a lot of experience in
the left but he looked like a wily
veteran there
mayor field says what am i going to do
when a guy makes a play like that
all you can do is smile and say well
done miguel cabrera leads things off
up the middle and a kick save and a
beauty by barlow the throw to first
brings santana off the bag the layoff
man is aboard here's the sock paradis
and you could argue he's had the best
at-bats for the tigers today now the
one-two
[Applause]
so that puts the tying run at third in
the winning run at second
and nico goodram will bat
and goodrum
went around
an intentional walk to robbie grossman
and now aj hinch counters with harold
castro
a foul tip
a strikeout and the royals hang on by
their fingernails
and beat the tigers this afternoon 2-1
and hud i don't know what you were so
worried about
we had them all the way